RONALD SMITH: We're going to be
talking
about a simple example
of systems analysis.
I put the term up here.
Almost everything we deal with
in science, engineering, even
everyday life, has
some elements of
system analysis to it.
The simplest kind of a system,
like the one I have here,
consists of a reservoir, where
you store things, and inputs
and outputs.
With that definition, I think
you can imagine a wide variety
of things that might
resemble this.
For example, the heat budget of
the Earth, which we'll be
speaking about next week, you
can store heat in the Earth's
solid parts and the
atmosphere.
You can have heat coming from
the Sun, which is the input.
You can have heat radiating
to space.
And it's the nature of that
systems analysis that will
help to understand the
climate of the Earth.
If you look at the hydrologic
cycle--
for example, let's look at
the atmospheric part--
how much water vapor do you have
stored in the atmosphere?
What are the inputs?
What are the outputs?
Only by understanding that way
can we really understand how
water vapor is handled in
the Earth's atmosphere.
The same thing for lakes.
A lake has a storage
capability.
It has inputs.
It has outputs.
The carbon cycle, there's
carbon in the atmosphere
stored there, inputs
and outputs.
In other words, almost
everything we deal with in
life has some elements of a
simple system like the one
we're dealing with today.
So this is meant to be--
nothing special about it.
It's just an analogue for many
of the things that we'll be
dealing with in this course and
you may run into in other
circumstances as well.
So we have to first understand
those three
components, the storage--
the reservoir itself--
the input, and the output.
So this is a thin tank
made of Plexiglas.
And the dimensions you will
need, the dimensions are here.
The inside dimensions of that
are 59 centimeters in length,
two centimeters in width, and
25 centimeters in depth.
So if you need to compute the
volume of this, you can do it
easily from those dimensions.
It has a little pipe-- a little
hole in the end at this
end-- you can't see it from
where you're sitting--
a short little pipe, a valve,
and then it flows out into the
sink and down into the drain.
We'll need to know that that
valve is about six centimeters
below the bottom of the tank.
I'll explain why that's
important in just a moment.
The input is this little
rubber hose right here.
It's controlled by a faucet, and
I can change the rate at
which water is flowing in just
by twisting that valve.
And then the output comes
out the valve.
And that's a controllable valve,
but I'm going to leave
it set where it is for right
now, and we're going to just
leave it and deal with it in
the form that it's in.
Any questions yet about this
simple system I have here?
Now, the inputs and the outputs,
we're going to use
capital Q for this.
It's the volume flow rate.
And it'll have units of
milliliters per second.
Or if you like, a milliliter
is a cubic centimeter.
It's a centimeter by a
centimeter by a centimeter.
And the way we're going to
measure that-- and Patrick has
agreed to help me with this.
If you can come on up, try that
stopwatch, try starting
it, stopping it, and then
resetting it over here.
OK, is that going to work?
So I'm going to pull
out this pipe.
This is a 400-milliliter
container,
400-millilier container.
So we're going to time how long
it takes to fill that up,
and then we will just get
the flow rate from that.
So I will give you
a countdown.
Three, two, one, start.
And as soon as that reaches the
top there, you can stop.
So the flow rate coming out of
the valve right now is--
Q is 400 milliliters
divided by--
STUDENT: 7.41
PROFESSOR: 7.41.
Can you do that calculation
for me?
400 by 7.41.
STUDENT: 53.98.
PROFESSOR: 53.98.
And the units on that
are going to be
milliliters per second.
So we're going to be doing this
over and over again with
different flow configurations.
Now, you can sit for
a few minutes.
It'll take a while now
to get this set.
I'm going to try to determine
the nature of the valve.
How easily is the valve letting
water out of the tank?
That's going to be a critical
part of our understanding of
this system.
And I'm going to tell you that
Q Out will take the form of
some constant times the square
root of Z Effective, where Z
is the depth of the water.
I think you would expect that
the deeper the water, the more
pressure there is trying to push
water through the valve,
and so the faster Q Out will be,
the larger Q Out will be.
So we have to determine the--
well, this constant.
This constant will depend
on how I have
that exit valve set.
And if I were to change it,
I'd have to redo the
calculation of K again.
But I'm going to leave
it like it is.
We're going to let this come
to a steady state for a
minute, and then we'll
do a calculation.
Now, what is Z Effective?
If the water depth is here, we
measure Z as the height from
the bottom of the tank up to the
water top, and then we add
six centimeters to it.
So Z Effective is Z plus
six centimeters.
Because that gives us the depth
all the way to the valve
itself, and that's what's
going to be
pushing the water out.
The point is, even when the tank
is empty, if there's a
little bit of water in that
pipe, that vertical pipe,
you're still going to be getting
some water running out
until all the water in
the pipe is gone.
And then of course, Z Effective
would be zero, and
then of course Q Out
would be zero.
So we're going to
determine this.
How are we going to do it?
We're going to simply solve this
for K. So it's going to
be Q Out divided by the square
root of Z Effective.
So let's do, Patrick, let's do
this calculation again now.
Let's do the Q Out first.
Are you ready?
Are you set?
One, two, three, start.
STUDENT: 8.37.
PROFESSOR: So what is Q Out?
You do the--
you do that.
STUDENT: 47.79.
PROFESSOR: 47.79.
Could you now measure the depth
of this, please, in
centimeters.
Come around and measure it from
the top of the plastic
there-- not from the
table, but from
the top of the plastic--
and get the depth.
STUDENT: It's about
10 centimeters.
PROFESSOR: 10 centimeters.
So that means Z Effective
is going to be 16.
So if you could do one more
calculation for me, then.
I need to get 47.79 divided
by the square root of 16.
Well, that's easy, isn't it?
The square root of 16
is four, so it's--
STUDENT: 11.95.
PROFESSOR: 11.95.
So the valve constant K--
thanks, we're done.
So the valve constant K
for that particular
valve setting is 11.95.
The units on that are weird.
You'd have to work out the units
from the flow rate here
and the fact that the Z is
inside a square root sign, but
we'll just leave it as
a number without
the units on it.
So we've characterized
the inflow
controlled by my faucet.
We've characterized the
reservoir, characterized by
its dimensions.
And we've characterized the
outflow by finding this valve
constant K. So now we know for
any fluid depth, we can
compute what the outflow
will be.
So we're off to a good start.
Now, we have to do a little bit
of calculation to protect
against disaster here.
So let's try to compute from
these formulas what flow
rate--what's the maximum flow
rate I could use before the
tank would overflow?
So let's see.
We're going to use--we're
going to assume a steady
state, in which case Q
In will equal Q Out.
And so I'm going to specify
some particular Q In.
And then the Q Out is going to
be given by this, the valve
constant times the square
root of Z Effective.
Now, what's the maximum value
Z Effective could be?
It's the depth of the tank, 25
centimeters, plus the six
centimeters to get down
to the valve.
So this is going to be K times
the square root of 31, if I've
done that calculation
correctly.
And could you do that
for me, Patrick?
What's that?
Use the valve constant here
and then times the
square root of 31.
STUDENT: 66.53.
PROFESSOR: 66.53.
So we're going to have to watch
out for that number.
We're not going to want
to put more water in
there than that value.
That's in milliliters
per second.
We predict a faster flow rate
than that would make the whole
system overflow.
So now let's see if we can
predict the level that the
water will come to when I change
the input flow rate.
So let's--
I'll take this out of here.
Let's see.
I'll decrease it a little bit.
We'll do a measurement,
Patrick, on the
new flow rate here.
You ready?
One, two, three, start.
What's the time on it?
STUDENT: 10.75.
PROFESSOR: Say again?
PROFESSOR: 10.75.
What's that flow rate?
STUDENT: 37.21.
PROFESSOR: 37.21.
So here's a proposal.
If I stick that flow back in
the tank, what water depth
will we get when it reaches
a steady state?
Let's do the calculation first.
Well, no, I guess we
can plug it in there
and get it running.
It'll take a while for
this to work out.
So let's do the calculation.
We're going to now solve
for Z Effective.
So again using the steady state
assumption, I'm going to
say Z Effective will be
Q In over K squared.
Is that right?
Yeah, I've just taken this and
solved for Z Effective.
So that's going to be
37.21 over 11.95.
And we will square that and
see what we get for our
prediction for the
water depth.
Can you do that for me?
STUDENT: 9.70.
PROFESSOR: 9.70 centimeters.
Well, now, that doesn't look
like it's going to work out
too well, does it?
Let's do a quick measurement
here.
I'll do it.
Has that reached
a steady state?
Yeah.
Right now, we've got three
centimeters in there, so our
prediction looks pretty
poor at this stage.
Oh, wait.
That was Z Effective.
So Z we predict would be six
centimeters less than that, so
that would be 3.7.
My Z Measured was three.
That's a pretty good prediction,
actually.
I forgot about that offset.
Well, let's do it one more
time just to be sure this
system works.
I'm going to crank up the flow
rate a little bit, and we're
going to repeat the
experiment.
One, two, three.
STUDENT: 6.06.
PROFESSOR: And what's that for
a flow rate?
STUDENT: 66.0.
PROFESSOR: 66.0.
I remind you of our warning.
Well, let's give it
a try, shall we?
It looks like that's right
on the margin of
what's going to happen.
So we will take a look and see
what happens with this 66.
The units again on this are
milliliters per second.
While we're doing this, we might
talk about a few other
elements of the problem.
Let's see.
Would anything up here change
if I made this tank wider?
What if this tank, instead of
being two centimeters wide,
were 10 or 20 or 30
centimeters wide?
Would, let's see, would this
calculation for the maximum
possible flow rate change?
It's a wider tank.
The reservoir is much larger.
It can hold a lot more water.
Would that still be the maximum
flow rate the system
could handle, or would
it change?
Any thoughts on that?
What do you think?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
nothing would change.
However, it would take a
lot longer to reach the
equilibrium state.
If you get the water up to a new
depth or to drain it down
to a new depth, it would take--
instead of just a few
minutes, it could take maybe 20
or 30 minutes if that tank
were wider.
But in terms of the equilibrium
states, for this
particular system, it is
independent of this depth.
Remember, the pressure that is
pushing water out the bottom
depends on the depth only.
It doesn't depend on how
wide the tank is.
That's the key.
This formula here does not need
to take into account the
horizontal dimensions
of the box.
So the equilibrium states would
be-- now, that's a very
interesting result and something
that would be
interesting to understand in
all the other contexts that
we'll approach in this course,
like the water budget, the
heat budget, the CO2 budget.
What is the role of the size
of the reservoir on the
equilibrium states and/or the
rate at which you approach the
equilibrium states?
In this case, the width does not
influence the equilibrium
states, but it does influence
the rate at which you approach
an equilibrium state.
Now, it looks like we've
almost reached
an equilibrium there.
And I wonder--it doesn't look
like we're in danger of
overflowing.
So let's do a quick test
to see if maybe
the flow rate changed.
Now remember, there are errors
in this calculation,
everything we're doing.
For example, there's a potential
error in this valve
constant, K. If that's off by
a few percent-- we just did
one test. We didn't do
a lot of tests and
find the best value.
We just did one quick test.
So when I see something that
doesn't quite make sense like
this, I'm wondering, well, maybe
there's an error in the
valve constant.
But maybe also there's been
some change in the rate at
which we're putting water in.
So, Patrick, let's just
check that flow rate.
In fact, let's do
it off the exit.
We'll do it off the exit.
One, two, three.
STUDENT: 6.34.
PROFESSOR: And what's that?
STUDENT: 63.10.
PROFESSOR: So that's a
little bit less than
we thought.
Maybe the system's not quite
in steady state.
Maybe it's still filling.
Or maybe the line pressure in
the building has changed
slightly, and there's a
little bit less water
coming into the system.
But it is pretty high.
It may still be rising slowly.
And so I think we're not too far
off in our estimate that a
66 milliliter per second thing
would bring it pretty much to
the top of the tank.
So I think I'd call that a
success, even though we
haven't quite proven that
it's going to come right
up to the very top.
I'm going to talk about a few
other aspects of this.
But before I do that, I want to
see if you have questions
on how this system works.
We've looked at it from several
points of view.
There must be something, some
part of it, you didn't fully
grasp when I went through it.
So let's have some questions
about what's
really going on here.
Anything?
STUDENT: I have a question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, question.
STUDENT: What, exactly,
is K, again?
PROFESSOR: The
question is what is K?
I'm calling it the
valve constant.
I've got an exit valve here.
Let me lift it up and show it
to you, if I can do this.
You see that valve there?
Uh-oh.
Sprung a leak.
Sorry about that.
I got you down there,
didn't I?
It's always a danger to sit
in front like that.
So there's a valve there that
I could adjust by hand.
And if I close that valve down,
K would be smaller.
If I open it up more,
K would be larger.
It has to do with the area
of the pipe that's
closed off by the valve.
I can derive this formula, by
the way, from Bernoulli's Law.
You may have heard of
Bernoulli's Law.
It relates pressure and velocity
in moving fluids.
And here I can compute the
pressure by knowing the depth
of the water.
And then knowing something about
the velocity and the
area of the valve, I can
compute the flow rate.
So this formula can
be derived.
But without knowing the area,
without going in there with a
microscope and measuring how
much area is open in that
valve, I have to treat K as
an empirical constant.
I have to determine
it experimentally,
which is what we did.
Other questions?
So let's see.
The formula's on the
board there.
Let's try to think about what
some of the analogies might be
with this system then.
The most obvious one
is with a lake.
If you have rainfall coming into
rivers that's providing a
certain amount of input, where
the lake exits into a river,
there's probably some
kind of a control.
Maybe it's a low dam, maybe it's
just rocks in the stream,
but the outflow is going to be
controlled by the depth of the
water, typically, in a lake.
Therefore, it'll reach an
equilibrium state very much
the way this one does.
The exit law will be a
little bit different.
It won't be this formula
exactly.
But there'll be some
relationship between the depth
of the water and the rate
at which water leaves.
Then equilibrium will be
very much analogous to
what we have here.
What about the transience?
Well, if you get a drought, that
would be equivalent to
closing this valve down a little
bit, and the water will
continue to exit from
the lake, but the
lake level will drop.
There's still water going in,
but it's not enough to support
the rate at which the water
is flowing out.
You might reach a new
equilibrium, or depending how
much I've closed that, this
might actually come right down
to the bottom.
We'll watch and see what
happens with that.
What's another analogy?
How about water vapor
in the atmosphere?
Now, it's not a liquid
anymore.
It's a vapor.
The input would be evaporation
from lakes and from trees.
The output would be rain.
Now, the rain, which forms in
clouds and falls to the Earth,
probably the rain rate is
going to be proportional
roughly to how much water
vapor you have.
So the loss of water vapor from
the atmosphere is going
to work a little bit
like this too.
You're going to have a constant
input, which is going
to be the evaporation, and then
as the humidity in the
atmosphere approaches 100% and
you begin to form clouds with
precipitation, that Q Out is
going to increase, and you're
going to reach a steady state.
And that's what we have most
of the time in the Earth's
atmosphere there's a
kind of a balance--
yeah, that one almost
bottomed out--
kind of a balance between
inputs and outputs.
Let's think about the heat
budget of the Earth.
So this is perhaps more
difficult to imagine, but let
the amount of water in that tank
represent the amount of
heat stored in the atmosphere
and the ocean.
It's getting heat
from the Sun.
The Earth is losing heat by
radiating it to space.
The hotter--of course, the
amount of heat that the Earth
is receiving is not particularly
sensitive to its
own temperature.
That's just how hot
is the Sun?
How far is the Sun
from the Earth?
How much of the Sun's radiation
reflects off the Earth?
Let's say that's a given.
Then the temperature of the
Earth is going to determine,
though, how much radiates
to space.
The hotter the Earth is, the
faster will be the rate at
which energy is lost to space.
So again, it's analogous
to this.
You're going to reach
an equilibrium.
The temperature of the Earth
is going to rise until the
rate of energy lost to space
matches the rate of energy
gained from the Sun.
Then you'll have an equilibrium
temperature for the Earth.
And if the Sun were to increase
its temperature--
let's say that's the temperature
of the Earth--
if the Sun were to increase its
temperature or for some
other reason we were adding
more heat to the Earth's
system, suddenly, we'd go
into a transient stage.
You wouldn't come to a new
equilibrium right away.
There would be a transient stage
where the temperature
builds up to a new value,
where once again an
equilibrium can be sustained.
And we'll see that here.
Every time I change this input
valve setting, we go through a
transient stage and
then approach to
a new steady state.
So that's the way climate works
on the Earth, as well.
Questions on that one?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Let's do that calculation.
The question is whether we can
compute the flow rate that
would bring it to zero.
Now, by zero, we mean empty the
tank, but there'd still be
some water in the little pipe
down at the bottom.
So Q--
to minimize or to empty the
tank, let's say, Q In to empty
the tank would be K times the
square root of the minimum
value of Z Effective.
When the tank is empty, Z is
zero, so Z Effective is six.
So I'll put six centimeters
in there.
And, Patrick, could you do
that calculation for me?
It's the valve constant, 11.9,
times the square root of six.
STUDENT: 29.15.
STUDENT: What is the K value?
PROFESSOR: Right there.
So that's a good question.
Now, whether that has any
analogue in these other
systems I'm talking about,
I'm not so sure.
For example, what
would it mean--
well, of course, a lake
could empty out.
We can imagine that.
Could we imagine the Earth
storing no heat?
Not really.
It'd have to be at
absolute zero.
So I don't think that minimum
could be carried over to find
an analogy in the Earth's
heat budget.
Probably not the maximum,
either.
I mean, there's no such thing
as overflowing the Earth's
heat budget.
Where's the heat going to go?
It's going to have
to escape again.
So not everything here has an
analogue with every system
that we're talking about, but
the basic elements of how an
equilibrium is reached, I think
that's the one that
carries over fairly
dramatically.
So let's imagine what would
determine for the Earth's heat
budget, what would determine the
rate of approach to a new
equilibrium?
I think in this case it would be
probably the heat capacity
of the Earth.
How much heat can you store?
And so we'd have to do a
calculation taking into
account the thermal heat
capacity of the oceans, the
thermal heat capacity of the
land surface, and that would
determine the rate at which
you'd approach the new
equilibrium.
Those things would not enter
into what the new equilibrium
state would be, but those would
enter into the rate at
which you reach that
new equilibrium.
So these nuances--
I call them nuances-- they're
actually of central
importance.
The difference between the
nature of the steady state and
the nature of the transient
state is quite important in
all of
these systems. Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The question is is there
analogue in the systems I
mentioned to the out valve?
And yeah, I think there would
be one, and it's one that I
should've thought about
to mention.
If we're talking about the heat
budget analogue, the heat
budget analogue is the Earth
receiving heat from the Sun,
storing some of it, and then
radiating it to space.
If I add-- if I have an
atmosphere with a greenhouse
gas and I add more greenhouse
gas, then for the same
temperature, it's harder to
get the radiation out.
So adding a greenhouse gas like
CO2 is essentially like
closing down this valve
a little bit.
So let me try that.
We'll do a little greenhouse
experiment here.
We'll pretend that this is an
analogue to the surface heat
budget of our planet.
And I'm going to add more
absorbing gas to the
atmosphere so that as the planet
tries to radiate, it
can't get that radiation out
because of the greenhouse gas.
So I'll close this valve down.
And watch what happens then.
I haven't changed the input.
Notice, I'm not changing
the Sun.
I'm not changing what radiation
is coming in, but
I'm changing the output.
I'm changing the output law,
so I've just changed K by
closing that valve down
a little bit.
So we're out of equilibrium.
We're in a transient stage.
The climate is out of balance.
And it looks like I may have
made a tactical error here.
It looks like I've closed that
valve down too much,
and we're going to--
of course, we have a new value
for the maximum now, because
I've closed the valve.
It looks like I'm going
to exceed that.
But anyway, that's
the transient.
I'm going to have to
open this up a bit.
I put too much greenhouse gas
in the atmosphere there.
So it reached a new
equilibrium.
It took a while to do that.
But we heated up the Earth.
Now it can get rid of radiation
at the same rate
that it's coming in, and we've
achieved a new balance.
So maybe that's--
thanks for that question,
because that provides another
way to think about the analogy
between this and the Earth and
the heat budget.
Was there a question
back here?
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, that's right.
That's the remarkable thing.
So the gases we normally think
of as greenhouse gases, like
carbon dioxide, methane, and
water vapor, they actually
don't do very much to the
Sun's radiation at all.
Those molecules do not absorb
those short wavelengths coming
from the Sun, but they do absorb
the longer wavelengths
that the Earth is
radiating at.
We'll talk about this
in class next week.
So this is a pretty good analogy
of that, because
adding greenhouse gas doesn't
change the input, but it does
change the output law.
It changes the relationship
between heat you've stored and
the rate at which you're
getting rid of heat by
radiating it to space.
So it's a pretty good analogy
to the greenhouse effect.
Yeah.
STUDENT: But so then once it
leaves the equilibrium then,
you'll still have the
same radiation?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
This radiation leaving will be
equal to this once again, but
now the Earth will be hotter.
The Earth will have
to be hotter to
maintain that balance.
That's exactly the point.
Yes.
You'll go back to a steady state
again where Q In equals
Q Out, but in order to do--
just like here, the new steady
state, Q In equals Q Out, but
now the water depth
is greater.
There's more heat stored in the
system for this analogue,
and that means the Earth
is a hotter place, a
hotter place to be.
Other questions on this?
Well, let me just do one sketch
then to make this
transient thing a little
bit more clear
before we quit today.
I want to get this
in your notes.
Thinking about this tank, if I
plotted versus time Q In and I
plotted beneath that the depth
of the water in the tank
versus time, let's say we
established some flow rate,
and it was in steady state,
and so the water depth was
constant as well.
Let's do a couple little
experiments here.
If I suddenly increase the
inflow rate, what would happen
to the water depth?
Does it jump as well?
Well, no, we did that
experiment.
Actually, it begins to
rise immediately.
There's a kink in the curve, but
not a jump in the curve.
So it rises like this and then
ultimately approaches a new
steady state.
And as we've talked about, the
time it takes to come to a new
steady state, the length of this
transient period in this
case would depend on the
width of the tank.
If the tank happened to be
twice as wide, say four
centimeters instead of two
centimeters, this curve would
look something like this.
It would take about twice
as long to get to
the new steady state.
To make matters even more
complicated, what if I slowly
increased the Q In?
Well then, this would
be even slower.
But that's because I've gone
slow on changing the inputs.
But eventually, sometime after
the new steady state for Q In
was reached, eventually the
new steady state for the
system would be reached.
So we're going to want
to understand--
in the case of global warming
later in the course, we're
going to want to understand
the rate at which we're
changing the properties of the
system, Q In or Q Out, and the
nature of the transient
response.
And I think that'll
do it for the day.
We'll finish a little
bit early, and
I'll see you on Monday.